[موسيقى]
امريكا تسمح اخيرا بتسليم هذا السلاح
للاوكرانيين والدنمارك تعرض المساعده فكيف
سيرد بوتين موسكو تحقق تقدما باهرا في
انتاج كميات هائله من سلاح بث الرعب في
اوكرانيا وتركيا توجه تحذيرا شديدا لهجه
الى روسيا لا تكررها مره اخرى وخطه
اوكرانيه لانهاء ازمتهم الاقتصاديه
بمساعده غربيه فهل يغامر الغربيون وضربات
الروسيه القاسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وكيف ترد بهجمات متواصله على موسكو وتقترب
من الكرملين وبعد اشتعال التوترات على
الحدود البولنديه الليتوانيه مع بيلاروسيا
اوكرانيا تدخل على الخط مستغله امريكا
وروسيا الصين تحدث نقله نوعيه في عالم
الاسلحه الفتاكه وكوريا الشماليه تعلن عن
مواجهه مباشره مع مقاتله امريكيه وبايدن
يخطب
والجيش الياباني
يستنفر
حرب اسلحه الجو المخيفه الصراع في
اوكرانيا يصعد قليلا ليجعل الجو ساحه له
والحرب اصبحت حربا جويه يا ساده وبين
مقاتله مخيفه ومسيره الضاربه ارتفعت حده
المعارك اكثر ليعلن مسؤولا امريكي ان
سلطات بلاده صدقت بتاكيدات رسميه على
ارسال مقاتلات الجيل الرابع من طراز اف 16
من الدنمارك وهولندا لاوكرانيا بعد اتمام
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على قيادتها
انها المقاتله المنتظره حقا في اوكرانيا
فهل يحدث وجودها فرقا في سير المعارك
ساترك الاجابه لكم ودعونا نكمل فمن جهته
اكد وزير الخارجيه الدنماركي لارس لوك راس
موسون حصول كوبنهاجن على اذن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بتزويد كي الطائره اف
16 بعد الانتهاء من تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين عليها الرد الروسي جاء عن
طريق سلاح خفيف الوزن رخيص الثمن ولكن
الضرباته موجعه عن مسيره شاهد الايرانيه
الانتحاريه نتحدث حيث نقلت صحيفه واشنطن
بوست الامريكيه عن وثائق ان روسيا تحرز
تقدما مطردا نحو هدفها لانتاج كميات كبيره
من احد طرز الطائره المسيره الهجوميه
الايرانيه التي يمكن ان تحلق لاكثر من الف
ميل وتستهدف مدنا اوكرانيا لننتقل الى
الميدان حيث اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه عن تقدم
الجيش الروسي على كافه المحاور والقضاء
على نحو 810 من الجنود الاوكرانيين وتدمير
26 مسيره اوكرانيه واسقاط مقاتلتين طراس
وكالعاده هي ارقام كبيره ولابد من مصدر
وهو ما ترونه امامكم في الموقع الرسمي
للحك الروسيه لتعود الوزاره الروسيه وتعلن
اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه استهدفت موسكو
وضواحيها دون ان يسفر الحادث عن وقوع
اصابات وقال رئيس بلديه موسكو ان الهجوم
الاوكراني الحق اضرارا بمبنى وسط العاصمه
واوضح المسؤول الروسي ان حطام المسيره سقط
على مركز اكسبو الواقع على بعد اقل من
خمسه كيلومترات من الكرملين وعلى ذات
السياق اعلنت هيئه الطيران الروسيه
استئناف حركه الملاحه في اربعه مطارات
بالعاصمه موسكو بعد تقييدها بسبب الهجوم
الاوكراني
فقالت ان روسيا اطلقت 40 صاروخا على مواقع
للقوات المسلحه ومناطق ماهوله بالسكان
والعهده على المصدر والذي ترونه ظاهرا
امامكم تقوم القوات الروسيه بقصف طول خط
الجبهه الممتد من المناطق المتاخمه فان
الجانب الروسي شان هجوما على المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها
الروسيه القاسيه تتوالى على اوكرانيا حيث
كانت الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت انها دمرت
قطارا اوكرانيا يحمل اسلحه في دينمبرو فيا
لها من ضربات قويه سجلت خسائر فادحه في
القوات الاوكرانيه ومن البر الى احشاء
البحار والمحيطات حيث اكد الدائره
الاتصالات التابعه للرئاسه التركيه انها
حذرت الجانب المعنيه في الطرف الروسي بشان
دعم سفينه تجاريه تركيه تحمل اسم شكر
اوكان مشيره الى انها تضمنت مطالبه بعدم
تكرار هذا الفعل الذي سيؤدي الى رفع حده
التوتر في البحر الاسود حسب تعبيرها فهل
بدات المناوشات البحريه بين انقره وموسكو
ولا سيما بعد ان ذكرت وكاله اخلاص التركيه
ان سفينه شحن تسمى جوزيف شولد وتحمل علم
هونج كونج انطلقت من ميناء اوديسا
الاوكراني عبر ممر اتفاقيه الحبوب ووصلت
الى ميناء امبارلي التركي الواقع على مضيق
البوسفور وذلك للمره الاولى منذ انسحاب
روسيا من الاتفاقيه هذا بالاضافه الى
البيانات الملاحيه والتي اظهرت دخول ثلاث
سفن جديده الى البحر الاسود متجهه الى
الموانئ الاوكرانيه احداهن قادمه من
ايطاليا اخرى من تركيا وترفع العلم
التركيه باتجاه ميناء
باوكرانيا كما دخلت ناقله نفطن ترفع علم
بنما قادمه من ايطاليا باتجاه ميناء
اسماعيل الاوكراني وكانت الخارجيه
الامريكيه قد اعلنت ان واشنطن تعمل مع
الشركائها للعثور على ممرات اخرى للحبوب
الاوكرانيه فهل يطول صبر الدب الروسي عن
تجاوز هؤلاء لتحذيراته وها نحن امام تحدي
اخر يتجدد امام الاوكران انه الجنرال
الشتاء حيث اشار خبير الطاقه يوريك رول
تشوك الى ان اوكرانيا ستواجه ازمه لا مفر
منها الشتاء المقبل ستتمثل في انقطاع
الكهرباء لاجل غير مسمى وذلك حتى دون تدخل
من الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه لكن في
اوكرانيا تخطط السلطات لما هو ابعد من
الطاقه والكهرباء حيث قال وزير الصناعه
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه الكسندر كاميشين
ان شركه اسلحه مشتركه مع الشركات الغربيه
في اوكرانيا سيمثل قوه دافعه لاقتصاد
البلاد وها هي كيا تخرج بعيدا عن نطاق
اراضيها ليعلن قائد القوات المشتركه
الاوكرانيه
ان قيادته قررت تعزيز الدفاعات على الحدود
مع بيلاروس رغم ان الوضع هناك هادئ وتحت
السيطره والتوترات هناك فقط هي ما بين
بولندا والليتوانيا من جهه وبيلاروسيا
وفاغنار من جهه اخرى
الاحداث والتطورات قال قائد القياده
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
انه يمكن للصين انشاء انظمه نوويه عبر
تجارب وخبره الولايات المتحده وروسيا وذكر
كوتون ان الولايات المتحده قلقه بشان
التطورات النوويه العسكريه للصين افادت
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه بان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت طائرات المقاتله بعد ان
انتهكت منطقتها الاقتصاديه استطلاع امريكي
قباله الساحل الشرقي وقال متحدث باسم
الاركان العامه للجيش الشعبي الكوري في
التقرير ان الحادث كان استفزازا عسكريا
خطيرا وان كوريا الشماليه تدرس اجراءات
لرضع اي توغلات مستقبليه من جهته استنفر
سلاح الجو الياباني بعد رصد اقتراب طائره
الروسيه قباله بحر اليابان وبحر الصين
الشرقي وفق ما اعلنت هيئه الاركان
المشتركه قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
في البيت الابيض جون كيربي ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مستعد للقاء الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي
دون شروط مسبقه لمناقشه نزع السلاح النووي
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه واضاف كوربي في
مقابله مع وكاله انباء كيودو اليابانيه
لم تستجب بشكل ايجابي لهذا العرض لكنه ما
يزال مطروحا على الطاوله
[موسيقى]